just so loud and in your face and
flamboyant this movie may be called thor
love and thunder but seriously behind
the scenes they were really bringing the
lightning the innovation in this movie
is bound to blow your mind if it doesn't
blow a fuse first number one we feel
like they took some inspiration from how
they staged the moon landing a brand new
lighting rig made the moon of shame
scene one to remember they seriously
took strobe lights to the extreme like
seriously how do you design what you
can't see the lights strobe in sequence
so fast that to the human eye it just
looks normal but in the raw footage if
you went frame by frame you would see
literally the same moment in time from
six different lighting positions per
frame they call it an undealt pack and
in post they take the pack and deal it
out based on which lights were on light
one light two light three all the way up
to six this has been used in
post-production before but this is the
first time ever in filming
number two well it's no palace but it's
home you wanted to live there you wanted
to vacation there and while it is no
gigantic palace as you can see you got
pretty much 360. it is the biggest set
most of these actors have ever seen this
is probably uh this is the biggest set
i've ever been on tessa thompson said
every single storefront felt like
somewhere you could walk into it blew me
away the cobblestones the attention to
detail and the tiniest nooks and
crannies that the audience might never
see as incredible as it is to see
advances in technology what's exciting
is when you can match that with
practical work that was so exciting on
thor love and thunder because we had
cutting-edge technology but many many
people worked hundreds of hours to make
something feel real that is just
incredible to get to work around new
asgard has insurance and uh we're gonna
certainly submit a claim and number
three we always wondered how they did
those reshoots it would be a pain to
have to set all of new asgard back up
after building new asgard the
environmental team took
295 high-resolution scans and lidars
capturing the entire environment this
was so that when they inevitably had to
do additional photography they had a set
to work with without having to
reconstruct new asgard too bad they
didn't do that with old asgard before
thor blew it up huh
production vfx supervisor jake morrison
was told you know what
we'd really like to do a scene with thor
and the hammer and natalie when
stormbreaker comes in at the end the bit
where the hammer's on a barrel and he's
standing in front of the shop front
didn't exist at all it was all done on a
barrel in front of a blue screen
outdoors in los angeles on a 30-foot
square number four leds are the future
and the future is here they projected
entire environments onto a circular room
of led screens it's a fully immersive
globe of televisions the ceiling as well
this is a huge step up from green
screens instead of actors looking at
tennis balls on sticks asking what is
this to the glorious response i don't
know it might be a dragon but it also
might be a flying dolphin the volume as
it's called made for an incredible
filming experience hemsworth said if
you're standing on the edge of a cliff
looking out at a sunset to actually be
staring into a sunset certainly pulls
out emotions and reactions that you may
not get using a blue or green screen
it's visually stunning because you get
the actual reflection off the background
a nice orange blow on your skin from the
sun it's a beautiful interaction that
occurs turns out they don't get to use
those led screens for everything though
number five the corpse of the behemoth
is a direct lift from rubik's comic art
down to the smallest of details
seriously it looks like they were
tracing isn't that cheating
number six sure exploding cars are cool
but did you see when tyka and chris were
throwing rocks at the cars for fun
somebody should tell their moms but
anyways here are some exploding cars
number seven omnipotent city has one
rule and one rule only there will be no
copying and pasting usually when you're
dealing with crowds of hundreds and
thousands you can be a little lazy in
post and copy and paste your background
characters however thanks to somebody's
big idea to have each and every god look
different this job was made much more
difficult jake morrison describes his
personal hell as no two gods should look
the same but it's the pantheon and there
are going to be thousands of gods in
there as they walk in and holy
and you get that steady cam shot as you
look around and see the whole 3d version
of that and taika's request was that
every single one of those gods had to be
different which again from a purely
artistic point of view let alone a
technical one
is a truly amazing challenge and then
every now and again he threw out a
special one like god of dreams and they
were like what's the god of dreams big
friggin eyeball okay there's a big
friggin eyeball or what about the god of
dumplings what's the god of dumplings
just a dumpling with a face costume
designer mayas rubeo said i gave taika
some ideas about what gods could be
there my pitch was why don't we
represent every god by how it's
represented in every religion you may
have an alabaster or terracotta god or
an aztec warrior made of turquoise inlay
she also made sure everything was
balanced having an equal number of male
and female gods she said anytime i can
i'll do that put things in balance so
many very original costumes and even
some that didn't make the cut and we
made them all number eight this reminds
us of when the carnival comes to town
you can just tell this isn't your
average film kids coming in to set up
for a class project in centennial park
in new south wales number nine does it
make you sad to know there's basically
an animated version of every marvel
movie you'll never get to see
morrison said if you know your cast up
front and that there are going to be
well presented digital doubles that hold
up for relative close-ups you try as
hard as you can to get light stage and
medusa captures in pre-production
however a lot of this can be put off
until post
number 10. literally everything gets
recreated imagine that checklist so at
some point the actors have to travel
there the guys need to be clean-shaven
sucks to be chris the light stage
captures all of the reflected values of
the skin which allows the vfx department
to get a good quality render of the
actor in any lighting environment but
then the facial performances like actual
acting and physical detail of the face
are captured with a rig called the
medusa that creates high resolution 3d
meshes for overall scanning of the body
and costumes they hire a company that
will be there for the entire principal
photography the same company will scan
every single prop before it's used and
after number 11 no we are not giving out
skittles that's the name of the scene
this movie is just going to double down
on ragnarok how vibrant the worlds are
this movie was criticized for some
pretty terrible vfx and places which
rude people worked hard on it guys and
the movie is still a ton of fun but
taika isn't disheartened he even
criticized one of his own scenes and the
color of korg
does that look real
in that particular shot no actually
number 12 screaming goats are the best
thing that ever happened to this world
it's classic goat boat well not really
once tyga is involved there's no telling
what could happen the goats and the
rainbow bridge and the votes are just a
lot of fun aren't they well did you see
the goats before they were quite
tediofied they actually looked much
chiller and far more similar they didn't
have the cute horns or ridiculous faces
they were just awesome goats number 13
virtual reality is changing the world
literally they used a virtual reality
rig with four sterilized headsets hung
from the ceiling morrison described it
best saying we would each sit in our
little swivel chairs and plug in and
then we would drop into an environment
that we were planning to build and all
the tools are there to fly around look
at stuff take pictures we had our full
lens kit what we were going to use with
the live action so you could actually
frame things up and look at different
angles and make adjustments we did that
for all the led volume stuff but the
most useful thing that since all the
real sets are created in cad before
they're actually built we were able to
bring them in and look at them with the
virtual reality gear for the new asgard
village taika waititi morrison and the
dp were flying around finding different
vantages and doing sun tests morrison
found it was a revelation for him and
he'll use it on every film from now on
number 14. it's always interesting to
see where directors draw their
inspiration tycha always wanted the film
to be a bombastic loud colorful palette
that reflected spray-painted panel vans
in the 80s and rock album covers ytt
said i remember spending months and
months perfecting the metallica local at
school to be able to use that stuff to
reflect the crazy adventure that we're
presenting visually was another one of
my dreams that came true number 15. we
know what you're thinking we don't
remember seeing taylor swift well she
didn't make an appearance in this movie
neither did her music but one odd thing
that did inspire it was the i knew you
were trouble goat meme video that's how
we got our screaming goats to nebula's
dismay you're welcome
thor love and thunder sure loves its
flashy effects it's so cool to see how
we are being propelled into the future
of movies
one day we will say goodbye to the
dreaded green screen for good do you
think all of this new tech makes the
final product better let us know in the
comments and thanks for rocking out with
us here at the things